yeah so this is quite an important
machine so if we are to say this is the
first personal computer then this
particular machine if zero number three
apparently as the story goes serial
number one was sent to popular
electronics magazine to be photographed
and that's why on the magazine cover
there is something that looks a bit like
this but isn't quite it because they had
to mock it up just before it was
published
number two's owned by journalists in
Silicon Valley and this is number three
now because of the type and the nature
of the machine you know these things
were sort of heavily they're modded you
know people would try and work out ways
of adding keyboards or a screen of these
oh and this is no exception
so what you're about to see isn't much
like the original setup for a an out
there and it's quite surprising as well
so is the big reveal so this is the
internals of our serial number three and
it's quite drastically different for a
start
we've got a huge hard drive here which
is very rarely found in one of these
machines so this has been big-time
upgraded this is the hard drive
controller on top and the the hard drive
and the or a Winchester Drive whatever
you call it this is a Western Digital
one you know this wood connects to one
of these boards the hard drive
controller is over there and then we
have a ram expansion board the CPU board
is in here so this one's not even the
original a TIG process anymore this has
actually got a z80 processor in it now
so this has had a whole load of work
done on it which is kind of the beauty
of it as well because that's what these
things were about we've got another one
of these which is pretty much his
original spec it's a later edition of it
not as low as serial number but that's
original but this one has got a lot of
history and you can see those changes
people are writing boards making it do
more and more that's the fun of all this
yeah and and this was so accessible you
know there were note sort of layers of
operating systems that you needed to
deal with and drivers and things if you
wanted to add another card you write
your drivers for it yeah as simple as
that
you got your screwdriver and you've got
your pen out and you write wrote the
code and you bunch something in there
somehow and that was the thing that you
know firstly they they linked to serial
port to it and then you could have a
terminal then they created keyboard
encoders and and display drivers that
a car called a Dazzler which was color
graphics you know on the machine that
sort of dates back to 75 there was all
sorts of things there's lots and lots of
these s100 cars available sound cards
just everything you'd expect today
and you did you probably made these
cards they were supplied as kits
sometimes and you put it together in a
configuration that you wanted it was so
open and accessible the s100 standard
was said standard so you could create
your own cards you knew where the pins
were you know you do what you want with
it and that's why there was so much sort
of creativity at the time people
creating new things for it developing
new boards and turning this into just
rather than just a basic machine with
LEDs and switches into actually a really
useable you know business system in some
cases with in this case here we've got a
hard drive that we have floppy drives
our 8 inch floppy drives connected to
them and all sorts so yeah really really
you know the electronics are software
engineers machine of choice in states at
that time you could buy one as a kit for
apparently less than $400 now that would
be the very very basic setup and you had
to build it yourself but you could then
add boards and you know you know the
cost would go up or you could buy one
really made and obviously they're more
expensive but then this was 1975 so $400
then he's not $400 now you know you're
talking I don't know about $1,800
roughly in today's money yeah so this
was quite a lot of money and it wasn't
just you know a cheap machine that owned
it everywhere bought that was a lot of
money to find at the time but people did
because it was new and exciting and you
know the beginning of what we know today
it does do but being American we need to
step down for it but but yeah it does
power up and I've never actually told in
any code because I'm not particularly so
80 based but it yeah it does it powers
up phone works you can toggle in things
and it does stuff but I've never really
had the time to sit down and play with
it much which is a real shame
eBay so this was at a time when I was
collecting seriously so I mean the
museum is born out of my collection I
had bought the machines that I owned
I bought the machines that I wanted to
owner couldn't afford I started them by
machines that I didn't really recognize
then I started buying machines from
abroad and it just gets worse and worse
or better about the way you look at it
and this thing come up and I've watched
a documentary about computing in the
States at that time and this machine was
on their own artists are on need to have
this bad boy and I didn't I bid on it I
end up bidding in binary for it a stupid
figure eleven thousand eleven hundred
eleven dollars doesn't he and got it for
a little bit less than that but I had to
have it especially because of its
history and the paperwork that we've got
with it that talks about who had it and
how it came to be so yeah it was
probably paid quite a bit too much for
it but hey you know it's see what number
three I thought that the gods have to be
on my side if I think I see holy I think
there was a guy in Sweden that also had
similar figures in his mind and yeah it
went up a lot further than I thought but
hey we got it now it's really nice
because it's that people to a point in
history where you see home computing
personal computing and really start to
take off it had to be in the collection
and then we've had it sat on the back of
the shelves on the IT Crowd as well so
it's had a little secret sort of stardom
if you look at where at Moss is sitting
this thing sits on the shelf behind him
along with some other random stuff as
well that we supplied I think they did
another version for the states in fact
but actually I mean when we sort of
blogged about it and put it on our
website I think there's a Polish site
out there that sent us a ton of traffic
there were big-time into the IT Crowd
and yeah they were they were really
quite into that and yeah it's it's been
picked up quite a few times it's kind of
that in joke
so you know the producer of the show
wanted to have something there that
other techies would record on go behind
me at smelter so really and and it
worked and you know all these messages
coming in to say is that actually a real
one you know and yeah so now we put on
the show and it's just that little in
joke for comprehensive
Cubano sir take him out but what good so
this is the CPU card from it like I say
this is as EIT and must exit 80 in there
and got some address decoding and things
over here the ROM there for it so yeah
you wouldn't normally find a Zed 80 in
an outer but hey this one's special
these other cars we have over here
hundred pins on the bus they're quite
hard to get in and out but um this one
is a serial i/o card so this actually
had probably a number of terminals
connected to it we've got one two three
four serial ports there we've got
another card over here with more serial
ports on it so you got six serial ports
home off the end of this so it's
possible that it was doing some
concurrent CPM I wouldn't live in the
eighties were good for CPM and
concurrent CPM so yeah I think this was
probably doing some kind of decent
business operation so in this today
speed that means basically they could
have had a few dumb terminals where
several people were sharing
yeah yeah logged in at the same time all
using machine at same time a lot of
businesses had various forms of s 100
computers at that time still a sea-based
and we're using it for the business
database type stuff and all sorts of
things
although the machines were pretty
rudimentary they would still get them to
do quite a lot just doing it in a text
based system so yeah they were looking
after accounts and also something CPM is
very much like DOS so it's all command
line stuff you could do directories of
the what's on the hard drives you could
create word processor files save them
load them different people can be doing
different things that even time so
that's kind of impressive really for
that kind of machine at that time
bearing in mind that go to the 80s and
we've got things like spectrums and
and other machines out there that using
said 80s but they're all sing strictly
single-user stuff so previously yeah
they were getting a lot of use out of
those relatively inexpensive and
low-power processors
people like Steve Jobs well no people
like Steve Jobs Steve Jobs actually saw
this machine and and thought well okay
this is a start but it's not the
computer I want this I want a machine
that you can actually type on and comes
up on the screen